what do you think of 2024 you think
desantis or trump
uh i think both will run
uh i've talked to people who talked to
trump literally i got a nice note from
trump the other day you think desantis
is going to run i think
has to run everybody seems to really
want him he has to run and i want him to
run because i want a tough primary yeah
i want the best person in 2024
that makes a lot of sense go after
desantis
oh
that's such a good question because
trump look how he roasted elon yeah it
was hilarious it was funny but yeah was
it really that effective i don't know
well i mean
like what's effective about roasting
elon they're not really up against each
other it's just trump slapping him you
know figuratively
so
but with trump and desantis desantis is
why is wildly popular especially among
trump's base
and he's he's succeeded on every front
he's doing great it's tough for trump
because you know he has this guy and de
is a smart guy he's not going to attack
trump he's going to go you know i know
the president's running i'm running on
my record i respect the president and
i'll be happy to support him if the uh
voters choose him here's what i've done
in florida now what's trump do that
would actually be effective that would
be super effective that really would be
uh take the high road what's trump do
does trump attack well you know sweaty
ron desantis
and it's like or whatever and he'd be
like yeah i work hard he's like i'm in
florida
he'd just laugh and go well you know
president trump he's he's a funny guy
here's what i've done in florida
you know and i'd like to you know draw
your attention to my successful
personnel uh policies right you know
like like i say for every rick grinnell
and robert o'brien uh trump's got like
10 john bolton's okay
actually i heard his mustache actually
had to separately get a security
clearance
so so trump says he's going to drain the
swamp for whatever reason it didn't
happen maybe it's because
he brought bolton he was like i'm gonna
drain the swamp and the first thing i'm
gonna do is i'm bringing the biggest
swamp monster possible
it was a mixed record yes um
and i talk about in the book i have the
last two chapters last chapter uh second
last analyzes all the potential
candidates and talks about trump and
desantis and how i want a primary to
hone the winner i want a strong winner
the last chapter is a president looking
back
as he passes it on to his vice president
rick grinnell and um
how he how he went and did this and and
part of that's the military thing i
talked about but there's a lot of things
to do and you need a president who knows
what time it is and has the strength to
commit the time to fixing these things
rather than just dealing with the you
know squirrel of the day
i kind of think desantis you know
we'll see what happens moving forward
my concern with the tennis is foreign
policy because we haven't seen that and
donald trump i think did really well on
foreign policy oh he didn't believe his
whole bilateral trade thing like his all
of those agreements where it was like
you know two like agreement between the
u.s and one other country i thought
those were effective what are those
called those
yeah
this he settled the middle east yeah i
mean those those are cool that was great
you know
i think that was kushner right yeah
kushner was involved and then you had
like the uae accepting flights from
israel which was really cool kosovo and
serbia that was cool negotiated by
grinnell yeah
it's amazing domestic issues desantis
does very very well
uh particularly in florida and coco was
a big deal so i i think the economy
would do well yeah but my fear is
trump has got let's just say uh
character flaws is a simple way to put
it yes in how he handles things he lacks
discipline sure but he was he did well
by the economy yes he did well by
foreign policy yes he did well in the
culture war yes and he didn't handle
himself as well as he should when it
came to the media true but people liked
that he smacked the media down
ron desantis seems to have
all that plus the tact
but what if we vote for desantis and all
of a sudden it's like middle eastern
wars again that's why you have to have
this is why you like cornell right
that's i love grinnell uh grinnell a
personal friend and uh look i i would
sit with grinnell and when he was going
over to germany and he would ask me
you know when i go to an army base what
do i look for
not like hey i'm going to have some
parties at the embassy what do i go for
what what am i looking forward to base
to see if it's working right and i would
talk to him for hours about this stuff
i'm very impressed but i mean we need a
primary to to suss that out right
because that's your question i want to
rick you know or says we don't know what
you think about foreign policy tell us
how about endless wars where do you come
on down on those you know i will say
this uh having luke rodkowski on this
show just like ardently defended
desantis over and over again i'm like
that's an endorsement luke hates the
government he has basically every single
politician and he's like ron desantis
what do you say he saved it saved
america or something like he really did
man he i mean he made a bold stand in an
unknown area
against covet the way or maybe not even
against kova just for florida i remember
going to i went to cpac what was it in
like uh
2021
in orlando florida
yeah and i was just like oh my god it is
paradise it was i think so nice
it was amazing people were nice you
could go out for drinks and everyone
would smile at you and there were there
were people to bring you food and it was
like they were happy it was so beautiful
i think i wrote an article that was like
florida is a paradise of freedom i'm
pretty sure that's what i called it and
then i had to go back to new york and i
was just like oh god no why
west virginia i i think the issue with
with i like west virginia florida was uh
fan yeah west virginia is great florida
was dense now florida is dense and so
you had this dense urban
environment that people who live in
cities like and desantis are like you
get your freedom so all of a sudden
people who like living in cities are
like you got to be in florida west
virginia has freedom
but it's because you're in the middle of
an empty field
which i i love because there's
yeah your neighbor is like all far away
like i don't care what you're doing and
you're like me neither i kind of love i
don't care
i think that's brilliant yeah i like
west virginia um
they they for the most part i don't
think there's any lockdowns in west
virginia i'm not sure not when we were
here how would how would i know they're
going to come find they had masks though
they're in masks in la again apparently
oh yeah okay but la is stupid i know
another stupid thing sadly i live there
yeah i live in new york city but i'm not
going to people walking around in masks
but you know what we really have we have
actually something that's probably
stupider than anything you have which is
for a long time after the mask rules
were lifted the mask rules were not
lifted on people under five years old
sometimes you'll have this you'll have
you know white over-educated liberal
people walking around new york city with
no masks walking a toddler next to them
with a mask on the toddler
were the kids on leashes yes the kids
will be on leashes they have those
little monkey backpack leashes you know
wow yeah so
they're just normalizing bonds that's
just insane well they are doing that the
washington post wants us to do that
remember they ran that article about how
important it is to expose your kids to
kink at pride gross
fatherly actually i didn't know wow i
didn't see that i didn't see the
washington post uh endorsing eric
greitens that's it was two years ago it
was two years ago that they ran the uh
bring your kids to show them can't get
pride show them kings that's what you
has the advantage over trump oh so if
you look at predicting i agree uh trump
said it's like 35 to santa's 42 trump
but i think
ronda said has an advantage in that he's
actively in government right now he's
campaigning right now which means he's
getting to prove himself
right now trump's trump might announce
his presidency early that's the that's
the idea that he's he's announced at
seven but he looked for it just before
christmas right and so but
and he has to because desantis is
actively campaigning now for his
governorship
but this means he gets to campaign
actively and be in the press and get a
bunch of attention trump if he sits back
he's losing that space to desantis yeah
do you think newsom is going to try and
run yes oh god i hope so he's uh he's
second in line unpredictable behind
biden i believe really yeah what about
camilla she's not the worst neighbor she
can get a single delegate she's
remarkable
another proud day for us california
lawyers as as someone who voted for
trump i fear kamala being the candidate
we
must
oh no not that don't throw me in the
camel patch you know what's funny is uh
it's funny that i basically said that
about joe biden and then joe biden
and so i'm like
you know uh we're we're sitting here
talking about kamal like ha ha kamala
and then well
it's like a democrat three percent of
the vote in the in the democratic
primary well it's like the democrats
interfering in the republican primaries
they're like let's give the let's get
like 10 million bucks this super trumpy
guy with mega tattooed on his uh [ __ ]
stamp and uh yeah we'll get him and you
know some of these guys are going to get
elected
in a world of seven dollar gas you may
get a guy
uh you know who who changed his name to
john q maga
and a magog you know this guy seems like
a viable candidate here in colorado yep
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm we'll see you all there
you